[Música]
universalizar esse é o tema do evento e
esse tema combina bastante bem com
abordagem que eu venho estudando
afetividade ao longo dos últimos anos é
espero que isso fique razoavelmente
claro pra vocês ao longo desta palestra
eu gostaria de começar então com uma
pergunta o que a vida sem afetividade
buscando estratégias de encaminhar
respostas possíveis respostas a isso com
vocês aqui no contexto do ted é surgiu
há a sugestão de contar uma história
então eu decidi se encontrar uma
história compartilhar uma história com
vocês e eu vou chamar de a história da
menininha a era uma vez uma menininha e
essa menininha era muito incomodada ou
se sentia muito incomodada quando ela
via as pessoas ligarem desde muito
pequena e há o sentimento de desarmonias
a incomodava a afetava profundamente na
escola nela com o passar dos anos as
coisas não melhoraram muito não via
bullying a ela observa o comportamento
das pessoas e as suas consequências e
ela começou a ficar preocupada quando
ela conheceu a matéria de história na
escola ela ficou ainda mais assustada ao
ver como o momento e sidão os desenlaces
das situações de conflito que o
restaram tantos desastres na nossa
história na história que nós carregamos
bom é mais essa menina era muito curiosa
gostaria de saber e entender por que as
pessoas brigam tanto mas não só isso ela
gostaria de entender um variadas outras
coisas incluindo as motivações das
pessoas é porque as pessoas fazem coisas
porque as pessoas se movimentam porque
as pessoas vão os lugares porque as
pessoas casam porque as pessoas têm
filhos porque as pessoas trabalham
porque as pessoas estudam porque as
pessoas compram tanto é e à medida que
foi observando pensando sobre isso ela
foi ficando cada vez realmente é mais
preocupada com as coisas aparentemente
contraditórias que acontecem com os com
as pessoas como seres humanos
a questão da contradição é o seguinte
por que pensam sobre isso não é difícil
concluir que no fundo nós fazemos as
coisas porque nós queremos nos conectar
nós queremos vivenciar interações nós
queremos nos entrelaçar nós queremos
vivenciar as sensações agradáveis
no fundo o que as pessoas desejam e
afetividade e variadas formas com
variados objetos no mundo com pessoas
no fundo é por isso porém paradoxalmente
existe uma grande dose de desrespeito
nas interações as pessoas parecem cm
perdidas nessa questão em geral né
e nessa questão de como viver as
interações e como buscar esse prazer a
variados tipos de desrespeitos nós vemos
entre humanos entre a humanos com o
restante do mundo e as consequência
disso as conseqüências disso são
terríveis né
nós convivemos com coisas como
fundamentalismos de vários tipos
políticos religiosos reais intelectuais
nós vemos a degradação do ambiente
natural
nós vemos desequilíbrios sociais é
crimes de guerras e violências de
diversas maneiras
é isso leva as pessoas a ficarem tristes
deprimidas e convivemos com altos níveis
de angústia em nossa sociedade hoje o
que aconteceu com a menina ea menina foi
crescendo foi crescendo é tornou-se uma
moça e passou a estudar os psicólogos
os cientistas que pesquisam as relações
humanas como eles explicam o o o fato
das pessoas se desentenderem com tanta
freqüência né e se tornarem tão
infelizes
por conta disso né mas as explicações
não foram totalmente satisfatórias é
muitas vezes têm muitas informações é
resultado de estudos mas é fragmentadas
por vezes encontradas e enfim e ela
continuava preocupada com isso é bom
usando se passaram na e essa moça
conheci um rapaz esse rapaz também
pensava muito também tinha muitas
perguntas também preocupações parecidas
com as dela e eles tentaram então eles
como eles se unirão né
resolveram unir esforços para juntos
tentarem entender melhor tudo isso a
primeira coisa que eles fizeram foi
universalizar a há a noção de
efetividade porque é não somente as
pessoas que afetam mutuamente são
afetadas e afetam aos as outras mas
também todas as coisas no universo
todas as coisas que afetam e são
constantemente afetadas e como
afetividade ampliada
nomearam como afetividade ampliada isso
há essa ideia da noção de afetividade
como afetividade ampliada pode auxiliar
a compreender aqueles problemas que
afligiam a cabeça da menininha né agora
moça e do menininho agora rapaz
eles entenderam que a afetividade de
verdade aquela que não é só restrito a
idéia comum de abraços beijos e olhares
carinhosos essa afetividade ampliada só
acontece quando nesse jogo de apitar e
será afetado
ambos os lados buscam preservar a si
mesmos mas também preservar o outro e
afetividade entra entre eles como uma
conquista
falava-se de pontes aqui hoje né entra
como uma ponte como um elo de ligação
entre esses dois lados né pelo qual vão
é vão circular trocas possibilidades e é
esse terceiro elemento fórum circuito
dinâmico em que tanto o euro quanto o
outro vão ser devidamente considerados e
preservados
entendo assim outro aqui por algo ou
alguém é muito ampla possibilidade do
que pode ser esse o então entende se que
a afetividade é a capacidade de afetar e
de ser afetado
mantendo se a si mesmo e preservando o
objeto de interação ou de conexão ou de
entrosamento
afetividade assim ampliada de nota que
precisamos buscar equilíbrio e
coordenação mais interações visando a
estabilidade e harmonia porque do
contrário
é o que acontece é quando um dos lados
centra se á apenas nos seus interesses
nos seus medos nos seus anseios nas suas
conveniências é e ignora ou anula ou
desconsidera o outro lado é não não não
vou conseguir se coordenar não vão
conseguir a formar o ciclo em que algum
alguma chance de equilíbrio e harmonia e
portanto a dinâmica internacional será
ameaçada
é interessante lembrar que quando essa
dinâmica internacional é ameaçada o
próprio eu
em princípio estava centrado em si mesmo
quando quebra todo esse ciclo ele também
não tem garantia nenhuma da sua
preservação porque nós somos seres
sociais precisamos dos outros
bom nós somos afetados constantemente
diferentes coisas ao mesmo tempo ea
falta de coordenação e meio a essas
forças que gera confusão o que é também
ameaça nossa preservação porque porquê
disso deriva algumas situações bem
complicadas e que nós temos vivenciado
parâmetros dispersos nós não sabemos
direito aqui valores aderir complexifica
ções várias de conceitos de idéias
engessamentos falta de confiança falta
de propósitos
o que leva a um engajamento sem causas
por vezes bastante questionáveis
violências de diversos tipos e nesse
contexto de confusão
o que nós vemos decisões bastante
primeira áreas
nós temos assistido no encaminhamento de
nossas vidas
por exemplo se nós pensarmos que 45% da
comida produzida no mundo é desperdiçado
enquanto tanta gente passa fome é no
mínimo um bom exemplo de que algumas
alguns
- não estão indo muito bem fora isso nós
temos vários outras coisas a gente né
algumas imagens seguem a equipe me de
algumas coisas bem inquestionáveis que a
gente faz o excesso de trabalho
ganância exploração de diversos tipos
ainda os nossos ambientes consumismo
desenfreado
nós vivemos uma postura de patologização
enfraquecimento de nossa própria vida
orgânica nós privilegiamos a construção
de hospitais e abuso de medicação pra
tentar remediar doença sendo que a
prioridade deveria ser ensinar as
pessoas a viverem mais saudavelmente as
interações né vivenciamos uma dose
bastante questionável de descontrole de
uso da instrumentalização né
nós podemos considerar que me por vezes
há um descontrole esse uso
enquanto nós subestimamos a nossa vida
psíquica a nossa vida internacional em
função dos instrumentos
então tão freqüentes lapsos né digamos
de incompetência no encaminhamento de
nossas vidas de problemas tão grandes
que nós temos criado há a moça eo rapaz
da história começaram a se questionar
mas será que nós estamos virando um bis
estamos pedindo à autonomia sobre nossas
vidas nós que nós consideramos né a
espécie mais inteligente do planeta
terra que tá o que está acontecendo por
outras perguntas né como suportar um
vasinho essa sensação de vazio que surge
diante de problemas aparentemente
insolúveis a vida sem afetividade é
realmente vida
nós precisamos de fato estar assim
existir
existe alguma outra saída é bom
a moça eo rapaz então eles concluíram
não vida sem afetividade não é vida
eles começaram a lembrar de experiências
relatadas em filmes as músicas de
episódios reais em que a repentinamente
uma ressignificação da atividade e
diante de momentos de crise e de antes
de momentos é críticos por exemplo
grandes desastres há a iminência da
morte nesses momentos nós tomamos
consciência da poder da afetividade e da
necessidade da afetividade nossas vilas
boas ilustrações disso no cinema não é
por exemplo o filme dia em que a terra
parou ou numa outra perspectiva beleza
americano quando que mostram que quando
nós estamos realmente no limite à beira
do precipício como dizem coisas tão
essenciais como afetividade a
importância dela se tornam claras
o desastre aéreo com que nove nós
soubemos no nosso meio aqui que
aconteceu recentemente em 2006 com o
time do que o time da chapecoense o que
aconteceu o que a gente viu né que a
rivalidade futebolística tão exacerbada
nos dias comuns né na nossa vida
realmente diante de uma situação desse
tipo o que aconteceu deu lugar a uma
afetividade janeiro
mas nós precisamos desse tipo de momento
para pra perceber o quanto a atividade
importante bom existe uma música dos
titãs que eu escolhi aqui epitáfio vocês
devem conhecer a letra deles mostra
muito bem isso né
devia ter amado mais quem deveria ter
chorado mais serviço sol nascer
é complicado - trabalhado - importado -
com tem problemas pequenos e ter morrido
de amor então
é nós sabemos viver afetividade né mesmo
essa atividade ampla mais ampliada que
eu estou defendendo aqui né nós
conhecemos afetividade nós perseguimos
afetividade nós queremos nos conectar
mas nós nos perdemos nessa busca muitas
vezes nós não conseguimos mantê lá né
com consistência e é a afetividade que
gera frutos na verdade ela está na
origem no feto na origem da palavra
afeto é ela que dá justamente a busca é
ela que sustenta toda busca nossa fé
busca de conhecimento de progredir de
nos desenvolvermos o que inclui nos
aprimorarmos cognitivamente para
encontrar métodos e técnicas para fazer
as coisas de forma mais eficaz de forma
mais assertiva é ela que dá realmente
motivos para as nossas ações porque a
vida com afetividade ela encontra a
emoção de viver em razão de existir nas
palavras daquela moça daquele rapaz que
continuam trabalhando pesquisando e
tentando aprofundar mais essas essas
questões e enfim assim termina a nossa
história ea minha defesa de uma uma vida
com mais afetividade
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]